black panther was one of marvel's most
important superheroes long before he
made his mark on the mcu but what are
t'challa's real origins and just why is
this character so beloved by comic book
fans
this is the untold truth of black
panther co-created by stan lee and jack
kirby the black panther made his debut
in 1966's fantastic four
number 52 followers of comic book
history will know that lee and kirby
didn't always agree on things but in the
case of black panther's creation both
writer and artist were in total
agreement
they knew that marvel needed the king of
wakanda to fill a void that it existed
for too long in comic books
the existence of a black superhero in a
1990 interview with the comics journal
kirby recalled realizing he wanted more
diversity in the comics he made
he said i suddenly discovered that i had
a lot of black readers and here i was
ignoring them because i was associating
with everybody else
likewise lee said he conceived black
panther with kirby because
in his own words he wanted to make the
first black superhero in a 2011
interview with alter ego lee said that
while creating black panther he was also
careful not to play into stereotypes
america was used to depictions of africa
as a backward and primitive place
so lee and kirby wanted to portray the
exact opposite lee explained
black panther is one of the greatest
scientists in the world and his area
this country is more scientifically
advanced than any when you get to the
hidden entrance and go down to wakanda
it looks like you're in a scene from a
science fiction movie of the 30th
century
when black panther first appears in
fantastic 452
his allegiances aren't exactly clear cut
he sends an emissary to new york city
with the gift of a high-tech flying
vehicle and an invitation to the team to
come to wakanda as the king's guests
upon their arrival however t'challa and
his subjects surprised the fantastic
four by attacking them
ultimately it proves to be a test black
panther hopes to get the fantastic
four's help in dealing with the villain
ulysses claw but first wants to make
sure they're all they're hyped up to be
eventually the fantastic four overcome
black panther but individually t'challa
is more than a match for any single
member of the team
he traps the human torch and easily
sniffs out the invisible susan storm
even when squaring off against the thing
black panther is able to hold his own
with nothing but his fists and his wit
in spite of their initial clashes the
fantastic four in black panther have
long maintained close ties
t'challa even took over as leader of the
team after the events of the lion wide
event civil war
it's no secret that t'challa isn't the
first black panther
his father t'chaka held the title before
him and plenty of ancestors before
t'chaka took the responsibility on their
shoulders as well and the further you go
back the more epic the black panther
struggles become
as part of marvel's legacy event from
2017
it's revealed that earth's first team of
avengers existed as far back as 1
million
bc thor's father odin leads the team
which includes prehistoric versions of
phoenix
iron fist ghost rider agamotto star
brand and
yes black panther 2. unlike t'challa the
first black panther wears the furs and
claws of actual panthers
in 2018's avengers number four odin
tells thor and she-hulk that this black
panther was the first to discover the
meteor from which wakanda harvests its
vibranium
but other than that not much is known
about this particular panther
not even his given name has been
revealed or whether he gets his
abilities from the same heart-shaped
herb as later black panthers
he's rarely been shown in action though
his dialogue reveals him to be at least
as intelligent and contemplative as
t'challa
avengers
assemble in 1999's black panther number
eight the king of wakanda drops a
serious truth bomb one that turned out
to be one of the most controversial
reveals in the marvel comics of the time
while t'challa and his avengers
colleagues try to quell a riot
mastermind by a cheby
black panther's teammates overhear him
saying he initially joined the avengers
because he wanted to see if they were a
threat to wakanda
once the smoke clears and his teammates
ask him about it t'challa confirms he
initially joined the team to spy on them
the revelation drives a wedge between
black panther and the rest of the
avengers and it's particularly damaging
to the friendship between t'challa and
steve rogers
while black panther would go on to be a
part of future avengers rosters things
have never been quite the same between
him and his super powered comrades
in 2018 writer christopher priest
addressed fan anger over the revelation
he pointed out to comicbook.com that as
the monarch of a sovereign nation going
off to have adventures with superheroes
seem like a strange choice for t'challa
priest explained i couldn't figure out
why he joined the avengers and the only
thing that made any logical sense to me
was black panther did it to find out
whether these people were a threat
once he was comfortable that they
weren't a threat he felt okay helping
them out from time to
time but his number one responsibility
was wakanda
the term graphic novel has become
popularized in recent years with some
people simply using it as a fancy
synonym for comic book
but a true graphic novel isn't just any
comic book it's a long form story
with a distinct beginning middle and end
in the 70s most superhero comics would
give you one or two part stories
but writer don mcgregor concocted what
some call marvel's very first graphic
novel and black panther was its hero
black panther's first solo series was
jungle action a title revived from
marvel's early days as atlas comics
panther's rage begins with 1973's jungle
action number six
and concludes with 1975's jungle action
18.
the story introduces eric killmonger in
his plot to replace t'challa on the
throne of wakanda and sends black
panther on the long and difficult road
to defeat his challenger
for a superhero comic to include a
13-part story spanning two years of
publication no less was basically
unheard of in the mid-70s
and doesn't even happen all that often
nowadays some have argued that it was
marvel's neglect toward lesser selling
titles that allowed for such creative
freedom
whatever the reason though you've got
t'challa to thank in part for the marvel
graphic novels that you enjoy today
t'challa is part of a long line of
warrior kings who have assumed the title
of black panther but some characters
have actually taken the name while
t'challa was still alive
more or less for example eric killmonger
defeats t'challa in one-on-one combat
during the 20th issue of 2000's black
panther run
earning him the right to become the king
of wakanda as well as the next black
panther
his reign ends in black panther 24
however when he eats the heart-shaped
herb which gives the black panthers
their powers and falls into a coma
because he isn't part of the royal
bloodline in 2002's black panther 50
after the rumored death of t'challa a
mysterious new black panther appears in
new york city
this new panther turns out to be nypd
officer casper cole
who swipes the uniform and uses it to
bring his corrupt superior officer to
justice
after t'challa reappears cole takes the
name white tiger and continues to fight
crime
even t'challa's own sister shuri became
queen of wakanda in 2009 during a story
in which t'challa falls into a coma due
to the sinister machinations of dr
doom t'challa eventually emerges from
his coma but shuri remains black panther
after that
until she sacrifices herself to save her
brother in 2014's new avengers number
24.
until the success of 2018's black
panther made more people aware of his
work writer christopher priest was a
largely unsung hero in the character's
history
despite its relatively low sales however
priests 1998-2003 run of black panther
totally redefined the character
without his work to inform it there
would be no black panther film or
at the very least it would have been a
much different and probably far less
interesting movie
as tadahasi codes another black panther
writer told vulture
he had the classic run of black panther
period and that's going to be true for a
long time
people had not put as much thought into
who and what black panther was before
christopher started writing the book
in 2018 priests told comicbook.com he
was initially hesitant to write black
panther but changed his mind when he was
told he could reinvent the characters he
saw
fit one of priest's guiding stars was
thinking of t'challa not as a superhero
but as a king
told through the eyes of t'challa's
hapless sidekick everett k ross
priest black panther is a colder and
more aloof version of the character who
places his role as king before anything
else
priest told comicbook.com he's not
allowed to think much about himself or
do much for himself his main
responsibility is wakanda he's not
really a superhero
the guy is a monarch he's following his
own agenda black panther proved to be
one of the most critically and
commercially successful
superhero films hollywood has ever made
but according to the late chadwick
bozeman black panther is more like the
godfather's michael corleone than he is
iron man or captain america
speaking to comicbook.com in late 2017
bozeman referred to black panther as an
anti-hero he said
at times black panther feels like the
godfather it's complicated when you have
to deal with who should live and who
should die
sometimes you have to do bad things or
you maybe need to do bad things so
there's justice so there's peace
fittingly bozeman's interpretation of
the character echoes the writing of
christopher priest who saw black panther
as a monarch responsible for his
people's well-being rather than a
superhero reacting to crises on the fly
bozeman even echoed spider-man's classic
mantra about great power bringing great
responsibility
the actor explained black panther is
about how you use your power what do you
do when you get power
in this case you're talking about
someone taking the throne but all
superhero movies are about a person who
has extreme power
the only difference between a hero and
the villain is that the villain chooses
to use that power in a way that is
selfish and hurts other people
the black panther film managed to work
in a number of the hero's signature
comic book bad guys
along with killmonger t'challa came up
against ulysses claw and embaku who's
known as the villain man ape in the
comics
are you done
are you are you done but while speaking
to yahoo movies in 2018 director ryan
coogler admitted there was at least one
bad guy he wanted to use but couldn't
craving the hunter coogler called
christopher priest's time on black
panther a heavy run and singled out a
fight that takes place between black
panther and the russian villain craven
as his inspiration for wanting to use
the jungle themed mercenary
cougler explained i've always loved
craven the hunter in almost every
iteration
so there was a moment can i grab craven
and they were nah you don't have craven
as he's a villain most closely
associated with spider-man sony owns the
film rights to craven and the hunter
isn't part of the deal that allows
marvel studios to use the web slinger in
their films
most likely the fight scene coogler was
referencing from priests ronaldo comics
as he impressively rendered battle
between the pair in the kitchen of the
new york hilton during 1999's black
panther number six
drawn by joe jusko the six page fight
sequence is an intense battle done
almost completely without dialogue
it's a pretty crazy scene and perfectly
encapsulates just how powerful and
innovative black panther comics can get
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one